welcome back to glam unfiltered host by
me josh smith and today we're joined by
the queen
of bond naomi harris oh b.e
how are you i am good
bond is back and he's having a bit of a
feminist makeover
what do you think that this bond
symbolizes about the society
we live in today i think this society is
no longer tolerant of the kind of
um representations of what it means to
be a man
that we had of old we have to make a
real departure from those
representations of masculinity of old
and we will not accept them anymore
i recently did a film where the
producers stood up before we'd even
started shooting and he said
this is an environment which is not
tolerant of any abuse towards women i've
never had a producer saying that before
how have you seen that culture change on
set
throughout your career what was it like
before and like you were saying it has
completely changed but what was it like
you know prime example for me is going
to an audition and having a very famous
actor
put his hand up my skirt during the
audition
and having the casting director there
having
um the the director of the movie there
and nobody saying anything
at all and feeling like i couldn't say
anything as well
um and now that would just never ever
happen
there's been this radical shift and it's
so exciting to see the power of a
movement like me too
that is in such a short period of time
has changed this culture
it's really wonderful do you feel safer
in yourself and in your own voice i feel
absolutely safer and i feel like
i'm encouraged to have a voice within
the industry i'm encouraged to speak up
um there are channels i can go to if
something were to happen
if i were to feel threatened or unsafe
in any way and that didn't exist before
i don't even know
where if you felt intimidated or bullied
on set in some way
i don't know where you'd go before there
wasn't that kind of channel
how has that been for you finding your
own voice and feeling
that you're able to use it in a powerful
way to be quite honest it's still a
challenge for me
because the culture was so radically
different when i was you know first
starting out as an actress
i still find it difficult and i'm still
having to remind myself
you have a right to be in this room you
have a right to speak up
um and you have a right to speak up
about behavior that makes you feel
uncomfortable
it's that kind of like a relationship
with your self-critic as well i guess
i guess yeah you know and it's also the
self-censor in me yeah that wants to say
shut up
it's okay get on with it be the good
girl you know
do what um you know is expected of you
do your job and
don't make too much of a fuss the things
you're saying like be the good girl
don't make a fuss it is that kind of
like
everyday sexism that is still so rife
in our society if you experience that
now
how do you shut it down you speak up and
you say something
there and then you say this film makes
me feel uncomfortable
and also if you don't speak up at that
time you don't blame yourself as well
because
some people freeze in the moment some
people aren't able to speak up in the
moment and that's all right but you do
something about it afterwards
because i think the reality is if you
don't speak up then then you allow that
person to continue with that behavior
and it will happen to somebody else so
for their sake as well as yours you have
to do something about it it's almost
like you have to have a responsibility
for the sisterhood
exactly that's that's exactly right
i mean your career is literally
incredible i was like looking up
everything you've done i mean i've
watched so much of it as well like
i mean you start down 28 days later
you've gone on to be oscar nominated for
moonlight
which was such a heartbreaking
performance
and i feel like for me watching you in
your career
you've kind of been a very quiet
activist almost because you've been kind
of making this space
for yourself as an actress as a woman of
color
how have you seen that level of
representation
change so for me when i started
obviously there weren't a lot of black
you know roles
for women i always set out with this
mission statement and my mission
statement was
that my job as far as i saw it was to
portray
um the positive images of black women
because i didn't think that there were
enough of them
so i always said if i get presented with
a stereotypical role
i'm not going to play it if it doesn't
move the story forward
about black women and show us in a
positive light in a strong light and a
multi-faceted light as well
then i'm not going to play those kind of
roles and it was really difficult in the
beginning because
you know i didn't have any money you
know i was trying to support myself and
i'd have to say no to roles that i you
know really actually needed to
build but it's so paid off i have to say
and that's one of the things that i
would say to
like the younger generation of actors
and actresses
that are coming into the profession know
your boundaries you know know what
you're trying to achieve within the
industry
and don't have anybody sway you from
what you truly believe
what has been like a hurdle for you
in that can you remember a hurdle that
you've really had to cut
overcome in order to get to the place
today
really like a massive hurdle well i
suppose it was at the time i mean
i was offered this role um by michael
mann of course who's one of the
hugest directors of all time and uh he
wanted me to do this nude scene
in miami vice i don't do nudity
and that's kind of you know a line for
me that i don't cross
and i'm you know it's not judgy thing
about other people who do do nudity it's
just one of my own lines you know
and uh he said well if you don't do
nudity then
you can't have this role so i said okay
well then i'm not gonna do this role
and my team thought i was insane because
they were like
what yeah like this is michael mann this
is such a huge opportunity in your
career but i said no and i was willing
to
walk away from it and thankfully michael
mann changed his mind and said
okay that's fine you can do you can have
the role i love that
yeah because you sometimes gotta play
hardball right yeah totally damn right
you've got to oh my gosh especially in
this industry
you have to be tough you have to be
really tough i was thinking when i was
watching you in so many of these films
when you're doing these stunts
you look so in control of your body
and you seem so powerful in your body
but i want to know like how is your
relationship with your own body image
change throughout your life to be quite
honest with you i've been really
blessed with my body because i'm i am
just naturally sort of
athletic and um naturally thin
so i've never really had to confront
just the kind of issues
i know a lot of my friends have had to
confront but i you know i have scoliosis
i was born with
um scoliosis and i had a um a metal rod
inserted along my spine when i was 15
all the way along my spine so
i spent a year in a plaster cast um
not able to scratch my skin or anything
like that and then
had to go through the whole thing of an
operation so that definitely changes
your
relationship with your body but what it
taught me is not really to
be fixated about the way i look but it
was more about the importance of health
and really i eat very very well and i
make sure that i look after my body
because
i know what it's like not to be healthy
i know what it's like when
you know all the muscles in my back were
cut through so
i had to learn to walk again and i know
what that's like i know what it's like
to spend months in in
hospital recovering from major operation
like that
it's not pleasant and uh so
i really work on trying to be as healthy
as i possibly can
and honoring the temple that's our body
do you feel
from those situations you become a more
empowered person
i don't know i sometimes look back and i
think almost like my younger self was
even more sort of empowered because
she had a vision for me and my life yeah
i'm so grateful to her strength and her
determination
and the fact that she she didn't listen
to all those people who said
it's not possible and you can't do this
and you can't achieve that you know
family members who said that there was
the only person who really believed in
me was my mum
that was so special it's so incredible
that you're out there
and you're such an amazing role model
for young women of color or just young
women in general and young boys
as well when you were younger where did
you find
your role models so my role model was
100 my mum
you know she was my inspiration because
she had me at such a young age she was
like
18 19 when she had me and she was at
school she had to stop school and to
to raise me she had nothing she didn't
really have any support and
um certainly not any financial support
but she said once you turn
you know five then i'm going to go to
university i'm going to educate myself
and then
i'm going to do what i want to do with
my life and that's precisely what she
did
when i was five and i started school she
went to university she got her degree
then she went on to become you know a
television writer she wrote for
eastenders for 13 years
she had her own sitcom on bbc one like i
mean she achieved
so much and so when you have a mother
who sets her mind on something and says
i'm gonna do that and does it
it's such an incredible example because
you realize like
oh it's possible for my mother my mum
did this i can do the same
how has that bond with your mum shaped
your career
oh my god it's everything it's
absolutely everything and that makes me
really emotional just thinking about it
because
i really would not be sitting here
talking to you and i would not have had
the career that i've had
if it wasn't for my mum my mum always
said anything is possible with hard work
you can achieve anything and i believe
in you and it's not just you know um
when i was starting out when i had those
moments of self-doubt i still have them
like after i did moonlight in fact was
one of my kind of
darkest periods in my prof in my career
because i was burnt
out because i worked three days making
the movie
moonlight but actually then spent six
months promoting it
and six months doing the whole awards
season and what have you and
it was an amazing experience but my gosh
is it exhausting because
i came into this profession wanting to
act i didn't come into the profession
wanting to kind of do all the red carpet
things and do
all the interviews and suddenly that's
what my life became about so afterwards
i went to my mom and i said mom i don't
think i want to do this anymore you know
i think i'm
i'm done i'm kind of finished with this
and my mom was like okay
it's all right you know take some time
out and then reconsider but
i know that this is what you're born to
do and she's always had that faith in me
so you
grew up in this council house you're now
this incredible
ob actress do you
still feel like you're doing it for that
girl that was in that house
i do it for every girl who's in that
position now
just to for them to know that anything
is possible
anything truly is possible but it does
require hard work
and it does require tremendous
sacrifices as well there's a lot of
sacrifices that i've made in my personal
life
in those situations and also like we
were saying about
the level of intensity especially with
like moonlight that you went through how
do you look after your own mental
well-being for me like my rock i need my
meditation especially after
a really hectic day on set because i'm
not really a people person i'm much more
of a kind of
loner and i i like i gain my energy from
being alone
and my relationship with my family you
know i live on the same street as my
family i'm just a few doors down from
them
so many people don't have the luxury of
you know coming from a family that they
love and they feel really connected to
and that is nurturing and i have that
privilege and i don't take it for
granted at all
what speaking of privilege what is your
like idea of the concept
of privilege and how's that changed for
you
you know when i was at cambridge i
really got confronted
with privilege for the first time
because it was confronted with these
people from completely different
backgrounds to mine
who would talk about going skiing with
mommy and daddy yeah
in the holidays and i was like what's
skiing like i've never
you know what i mean my parents like
took me to butlin so
i loved it i loved a bit of butlins
babes it was great
that's amazing so i i really was like
wow they are so
privileged and then actually you know
it's so interesting because the older
i've got i thought
i was the privileged one because i got
the experience of coming from a council
flat in finsbury park
having that awareness and then i also
got had the privilege of going to
somewhere like cambridge
and learning about that rarefied kind of
atmosphere that i was part of
i have an awareness of all these
different kind of echelons in society
all these kind of different ways of
living and coping and
and uh being in society that most people
don't ever get to experience and i think
that is the true privilege
if you could sit the younger you down on
this sofa right here
that was starting out in your film
career what is the one thing
you'd want to tell her worry less
enjoy more the thing i really struggle
with is overworking
you know i always think like your work
is never done um
and you can always do more and that's a
wonderful work ethic to have
but it also means that you miss out on a
lot of fun and i think
fun is just as important as work so it's
finding that work
you know fun balance that i really still
struggle with
i think it's such an amazing career
where you learn so much about the idea
of success and failure right
constantly and constantly and that's
it's always shifting as well because
you know you think like oh i've made it
and then you don't work again i always
remember when i got 28 days later and i
was like
oh my gosh this is it because it was
such a huge success and i was like
my career is off i am made now this is
amazing and then i didn't work for a
year and i couldn't get a job
you know um so it's a weird profession
like that and
those knocks are actually really
powerful to developing your
sense of self-esteem because you realize
that it can't be related
to anything external it has to be
something within you that you develop
that's such a powerful thing because i
don't think enough people think that
validation actually starts from within
right
it starts with your relationship with
your your own internal voice
you know if it tells you like you're not
good enough because you haven't done
this and you haven't achieved that
then what you have to look at is not
what's going on outside but actually
that voice because that's the really
damaging thing because
also the wonderful thing is you win
awards and you get all this praise
and you still don't feel good enough why
because of that voice
so it's the voice that you have to work
on ultimately it's your relationship
with yourself that's most important
oh my god you're amazed